welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is ban ki-moon the secretary-general of
the United Nations he is at Yale today
to give the george herbert walker jr.
lecture in international studies at the
macmillan center equal parts diplomat
and advocate civil servant and CEO the
secretary-general is a symbol of united
nations ideals and a spokesman for the
interests of the world's peoples in
particular the poor and vulnerable among
them Mr Bond took office in January 2007
in June 2011 he was unanimously
reelected by the General Assembly and
will continue to serve as the leader of
the United Nations until the end of 2016
mr. bonds priorities have been to
mobilize world leaders around a set of
new global challenges from climate
change and economic upheaval to
pandemics and increasing pressures
involving food energy and water welcome
mr. secretary it is truly an honor to
have you here with us today it's a great
pleasure for me to visit the Yale
University of game I was here January
2010
ah so thank you for coming again we do
look forward to your visits so while I
have so many questions I would love to
ask you today unfortunately we only have
so much time so I'd like to begin with
one of the more pressing problems in the
world the civil war that's going on in
Syria
what is the UN doing to help resolve
that conflict United Nations has four
priorities in addressing Syrian
situation unfortunately sadly the Syrian
situation is deteriorating by days
during last 20 month more than 25,000
people have already been killed billions
of billions of people have been
this place that we are seeing almost
half a million refugees around the
countries in the countries around Syria
for priority means they're first we have
to put an end to this intolerable level
of violence and start immediately
political solution second we have to
provide the humanitarian assistance to
many people affected by this at least
the 2.5 million people have been
displaced here and there and almost a
half a million people are being hosted
in four countries Iraq Jordan Lebanon
and Turkey this humanitarian situation
as winter is approaching will be much
much more serious and we have to protect
the human rights and human dignity of
many people there and fourthly we have
to unite the international community's
very solid and form a will to resolve
this issue the international community
has been divided let alone the people
over Syrian themselves we cannot
continue like this way I have been
telling prisoners that listen to their
people most attentively and carefully
and to stop violence
unfortunately the recent proposal by the
Joint Special Representative Lakhdar
Brahimi and myself for a even briefer
polls during Muslim holiday has been
neglected ignored so many people have
been killed
now that the opposition forces seem to
be united with electing their own
coalition leader and since you hope that
the opposition also will move in a
coherent way so that dialogue can be
started
what is most important at this time all
the countries who have influence on
Syria must not provide the arms and
equipment and funds to a POTUS eyes this
will put their people only into a
greater misery this is not the way there
is no military solution
there should be a dialogue there should
be a political resolution in this United
Nations is a firmly committed and I'm
also very much committed in addressing
decision ultimately that what do you
think it will take to resolve the
conflict
artemiy tree there should be an end to
violence then the representatives of
both parties I should meet and try to
resolve this issue through dialogue and
a political resolution they should agree
on their future of their own this is the
Syrian people a syrian-led solution
that's the best way ok let's move on to
two of the big global challenges that
the UN is addressing climate change and
food security I think most people would
agree at this point that under
undeniably that there is global warming
taking place the bottom line is what is
the UN doing to help save the planet I'm
glad that you raised the issue of a
climate change since I became secretary
I have put this climate change issue at
the top of the global agenda I have been
trying to sound alarms to world
community that that we cannot continue
like this way we cannot burn our way to
prosperity without realizing the limit
of planet Earth if by human beings use
our planet
planet the limited resources like as we
are doing we may have to have another
planet unfortunately and reality in
reality is that we have only one planet
Earth not two and we don't have any a
plan B because we don't have any further
resources we are stepping over planetary
limitations that is why I have been
urging world leaders to first of all
agree on the legally binding treaty by
2015 this is an agreement by the world
leaders that we will have to agree on a
legally binding treaty by 2015 this is
an institution a legal institution but
we have to mobilize and necessary
funding we have to help many poor and
vulnerable group of people because they
do not have any capacity to adapt and
mitigate the impact of this a climate
change then we have to establish Green
Climate Fund about the three weeks ago
the world community has decided to
locate the headquarter of Green Climate
Fund in the Republic of Korea where they
will have to mobilize a hundred billion
dollars annually by 2020 then thereafter
every year 100 billion dollars to help
poor and developing countries this is
absolutely necessary through transfer of
technology by providing a financial
support we have to put the highest
political priority I was very glad when
President Obama in his recent election
night when he was a declared winner for
second term he said about this warming
planet
that means he has varied in his mind a
high priority on climate change I'm
ready to work with all the leaders apart
I believe that the United States should
lead this campaign United State is after
all the the world the richest and most
powerful country and they should lead by
example have you spoken with President
Obama about leading the cause I have
discussed this matter many times he has
been quite committed in 2009 when there
was the United Nations Climate Change
Conference in Copenhagen he himself
participated with world leaders all
through the night and I was very much
impressed since then we've been working
very hard to address all global
challenges climate change issues
sustainable development the global
health issues women empowerment energy
issues and global education issues all
these issues global challenges should be
addressed by global participation
through a collective political will do
you think that the majority of the
world's leaders are doing enough to
combat climate change are they adding
here I'm sorry to say that the world
leaders have not done enough they know
that there's a climate change causes
without without we got to any boundaries
national boundaries whether you are
coming from which or poor countries
whether you are coming from Asia Africa
Europe
it doesn't respect the national borders
as we have seen recently hurricane sandy
even though we cannot say that any we
cannot attribute any one course to to
the effect of Jesus Hurricane sandy but
we have seen these days extraordinarily
powerful and disastrous extreme weather
patterns it's getting worse and worse
and worse and worse this is definitely
caused by climate change phenomenon the
science has made it plainly clear that
and there's a human being which has been
causing this a climate change of
phenomena and therefore it should be
human being that to address this issue
by preventing from happening again we
have a moral and political
responsibility to handle avoid this a
planet earth to our succeeding
generations for millions and millions of
years so that they can live in
environmental host hospitable and
sustainable way well hopefully the world
leaders will come together sooner rather
than later to work on this extremely
important that's that's what I'm going
to do as a secretary-general of the
United Nations just to raise awareness
on climate change issues I have been
visiting during us the five years all
the places around the world where I
could see for myself the impact of
climate change the consequences of
climate change starting from Antarctica
to North Pole the rainforest in Amazon
and Kilimanjaro melting melting is
everywhere yes or a certification as
well as a deforestation impact so we
have to stop the burning this greenhouse
gas emissions and make this planet Earth
environmentally sustainable food
security another huge problem for many
parts of the world
due to rising population and also rising
food costs
what is the UN doing to help deal with
that problem when the food crisis
happened spring 2008 I immediately
established a global task force to
address these food security issues then
recently in Rio de Janeiro during United
Nations conference on sustainable
development launched zero hunger
campaign it is unacceptable that even
today nearly 1 billion people go to bed
hungry every night it's a staggering
amount of people because of the price
hike because of the long spell of
drought or flood desertification
post-process we have limited
agricultural product but if you count
all throughout the world we still have
enough food there is a matter about how
to distribute this foot equally
equitably to people does the UN have a
plan for that we have here mandate we
have idea we are trying to make
everybody fed without any lag of
nutritions particularly it is said that
many billions of children die before
they celebrate the fifth birthday
so United Nations has raised the
campaign what we call every woman every
child our ambition is that during
forthcoming five years we will save 16
million lives mostly women and girls and
the children this has gotten a lot of a
support from international
immunity how will you save them now by
providing food by providing nutrition's
and the by providing the necessary
sanitation and health to support this is
to provide to every women and every
child the healthy service because so
many women and girls are dying
needlessly from preventable diseases yes
what countries are you focusing on there
are many countries particularly poor
developing countries mostly in Africa
enable Latin America and also Southeast
Asian countries there are many many
women who are dying while giving do both
then why should a woman die to give a
both right the our target is that a
woman in South Sudan should live as a
woman in Sweden can live almost 100% of
women in European countries they live a
while giving birth but one out of five
women and dies while giving birth this
is injustice
so in acceptable situation great United
Nations is paying a great attention on
this I have raised this campaign at
partnership with Secretary Clinton of
the United States and it has cottoned I
think most support from intentional
community good good very good well I
would love to chat with you for the rest
of the afternoon but unfortunately I
know you have a lecture to give so I
thank you very much for being here with
us today
thank you very much it has been a great
pleasure let's work together to make
this world better for why would we need
the support from academic communities
anybody is like Yale yes problems of
this magnitude need everyone to work
together
thank you thinking
for more information about
secretary-general ban ki-moon please
visit to the United Nations website at
UN org /sg
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale